hooky but it's like like it's very like
Chrissy Teigen Tegan taking a walk on
the red side here's me guys
yeah the model digital brunette locks
for a new fiery do debuting the fresh
style in this video
this is it take it or leave it of course
in the comments section hubby John
Legend couldn't help but Rave over his
wife's new look writing gorgeous with a
heart eyes emoji I'm a lucky man Chrissy
also shared a few snaps ahead of a rare
night out with Jon photobombed by two of
their kiddos seven-year-old Luna and
four-year-old miles it's so good the
hair switch up comes nearly two months
after the couple welcomed their third
child daughter Esty what do the little
kids think about a baby sibling be
around are they prepared are they
prepare to be big big siblings Luna
really
nurturing and so loving and so she's
just very very excited but miles is you
know not going to be the baby anymore so
I think he we spend a lot more time like
with him and telling him that he's
always going to be our baby boy and he's
like you know he's that's it for us so I
mean he's gonna be the best since the
arrival of their newest addition a
source tells E.T the family's doing
incredible miles and Luna are so happy
to have SD home and already adore her
they're both old enough to understand
what it means to have a new sibling and
it's been great I just don't feel like
anybody regrets having too many kids and
Chrissy's been sharing tons of pics of
the little one with her big brother and
sister giving so much to your children
and seeing them embrace it and grow from
how much love and kisses and tension and
affection they get it can be so amazing
as for Chrissy and John E.T Source adds
this is such an exciting time for them
as a couple and as a family they love
being parents and are thrilled to be
able to expand their family I know it
sounds silly if you don't have kids but
they say mama dad all the time but it's
weird when they know that you're the
mama and you're the daddy and you're
that it's it's just different it's
beautiful
[Music]
thank you